Hey everybody's Charlie this is going to be
my new Fantastic Four x-men Wolverine
Marvel phase 4 phase 5 video so
there's a whole bunch of stuff happening
Kevin Feige was talking about Fantastic
Four at Comic Con talking about
rebooting those characters rebooting the
x-men characters but there's a really
important reason why they were setting
the stage for Fantastic Four to debut in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe before
Wolverine in the new versions of all
these x-men characters so we'll break it
all down
we're doing a new round of a Disney Plus
streaming service giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your best Wolverine or Fantastic
Four theory on the video so why is
Marvel's Fantastic Four reboot movie
happening before Marvel reboots
Wolverine in the core x-men characters
well number 5 Kevin Feige was talking
about Fantastic Four way more than the
other Fox Marvel franchises at Comic Con
even more than Deadpool and Deadpool is
one of the proven box-office
earners Marvel is really excited to
start doing stuff with that character
without necessarily changing him he'll
still be rated R brand Reynolds has even
started trolling other MCU characters
particularly Tom Holland Peter Parker
spider-man because of all this Sony
Marvel MCU business listen to this clip
of Kevin Feige talk about the debut of
the new Fantastic Four team in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the
interviewers a little bit funny but pay
attention to what Kevin Feige says about
them Fantastic Four what story you're
going to tell that hasn't been told yet all
of that is spoilers but I'm extremely
excited about those characters and about
and about bringing Marvel's first family
up sort of to the platform and the level
that they deserve are you anywhere near
casting no no story no no no see all the
stuff we did today teases I just didn't
have time to talk about it
listening to that you can tell how
excited he is to do a new Fantastic Four
movie a good Fantastic Four movie his
quote about bringing them up to level
quote unquote that they deserve it's
just a little bit of a Kevin Feige burn
on previous fantastic four movies
usually you don't catch him doing sick
burns like that he's not completely
ignoring the x-men characters he did
mention mutants right after he said
Fantastic Four
the Marvel phase 4 comic-con panel but
they've been doing a lot of work before
this to try and set up the debut of the
Fantastic Four they even have that post
credit scene moment during spider-man
far from home so careful for spoilers
for the ending of spider-man far from
home if you haven't seen that movie yet
right at the end of that movie there's a
very notable billboard Easter a
Construction sign which is a bit of a
meta Easter Egg implying that Marvel is
constructing a new version of Fantastic
Four within the Marvel Cinematic
Universe like you won't believe what
we're working on next then you have the
one two three four it's a little bit
funnier now because of what's happened
with Sony Marvel and the spider-man
character potentially leaving the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but when they were
still making that movie that was still
part of the plan trying to see these
future movies like he says we're laying
seeds for all these big things that are
coming up in Marvel phase 4 Marvel
phase 5 just the same way that they
seeded the Infinity Gauntlet in the
early Marvel phase 1 films are you
already planting the seeds for the next
crossover event for if it's Secret Wars
or what like the space for start to
plant the seeds for whatever we're going to
see because we obviously saw Thanos and
the whole Infinity Saga the seeds were
planted way early on yes we debated what
we should announce today should we
announce four and five we've planned
them out we've got five years down the
road and I was like I think you got
eleven projects in two years they have
not started teasing x-men yet in that
same way that's really where the
Eternals movie and Marvel phase 4
comes and the Turtles movie is going to
help lay the groundwork for how mutants
can exist in the MCU and have been
around this whole time and we haven't
known about them till now before he says
they're still in early planning stages
for the new Fantastic Four movie they
haven't officially locked down and the
actors yet the reason why you keep
seeing the John Krasinski Emily Blunt
fan art as Reed Richards and Sue Storm
is mostly because it just looks really
really badass and those two actors have
a history with Marvel movies if you
haven't heard the secret history of John
Krasinski in Emily Blunt in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Kevin Feige and
Marvel were both after them for roles as
main a list avengers characters during
Marvel phase 1 when they were still just
kicking things off with the Infinity
Saga
they go way way
if you can believe it John Krasinski was
originally one of Marvel's first picks
as Captain America over Chris Evans for
a little while now watching all those
movies now you can't imagine anyone else
besides Chris Evans playing that
character he is Captain America
Steve Rogers but for a little while John
Krasinski was their early pick and Chris
Evans actually turned Marvel down a
couple times when they offered him the
role before he finally accepted this is
the hilarious story that John Krasinski
tells about why he didn't become Captain
America I heard that you screen-tested
for Captain America that's a goal in my
head I got the part yeah what was that
was that process like because that's a
real question you when you're trying to
think like am I am I one of those
superhero guys or not you know what I
want to do that could I do that so when
you had that test what was it like it
was a big deal for me because I mean
first of all I love those Marvel movies
I'm I love superheroes
I love imagination so when they asked me
to test they actually allowed me to put
on the suit I was on a set it was all
very interesting I feel like as I'm
talking about this someone from Marvel's
new book and just like yeah but I
remember the the only bummer of it was I
was putting on the suit just watching I
was like this is so amazing and I got
about right to my waist I was still
shirtless feeling pretty good about
myself wasn't 13 hours yet but nice it
felt pretty good
and all of a sudden Chris Hemsworth
walked by his door and he's like at
night and I went I'm good this is stupid
so listening to that he actually took
himself out of the role it wasn't that
Marvel didn't want him as Captain
America he just felt like he was not the
right person for that and you have to
imagine that this is all happening while
he's in the middle of doing the office
so he's primarily known as Jim from the
office while all this Captain America
stuff is happening I think he was
probably right to take himself out of
the running he's a great actor I loved
some of his other stuff that he's been
doing recently but I just can't picture
anyone else but Chris Evans being
Captain America right now if you haven't
seen any of the stuff he's been doing
recently though he's been doing way more
serious drama he did a quiet place his
own projects are blowing up he's
actually doing a sequel to that movie
right now which is why you haven't heard
about
doing any Marvel movies the last couple
of years you watch them in things like
the Jack Ryan series that he's doing and
it feels like a really good serious
version of Reed Richards imminent
Universal problem-solver someone who is
dealing with constant world ending
crisis universe ending crisis but the
reason why he's so important is because
he's the character that the Avengers go
to when they can't solve a problem three
emily Blunt's history with Marvel is
actually a little more well documented
by the fandom you probably heard some of
these stories for a long time people
thought that Marvel had been after her
for Captain Marvel
especially around lived I repeat because
she played a total badass during that
movie when Marvel was still kind of
trying to figure out what was going on
with the Captain Marvel character she
completely denies that she was ever in
the running for Captain Marvel but the
real truth is that she goes way further
back with Marvel just like John
Krasinski it's just a coincidence that
they're married to each other in real
life but both of them had been courted
by Marvel before they were married get
this though back when Iron Man 2 was
getting ready to shoot Marvel originally
wanted Emily Blunt to be their Black
Widow not Scarlett Johansson Scarlett
was not Marvel's first pick as Black
Widow just like Chris Evans though now
you can't picture anyone else playing
Black Widow but Scarlett especially
because we're going to get a black widow
trailer dropping in October to cut to
today Marvel needs it's fantastic for
its first family as Kevin Feige calls it
they have two super high-profile ælis
actors who they really wanted for
earlier roles that just did not work out
they've been after them for years to do
Marvel characters just waiting for the
right opportunity just in the same way
that they've been after Keanu Reeves for
years and usually the reason why you
don't see them is because they're just
waiting for the right character to come
along like oh you were the only actor
that could play this particular
character now they have that opportunity
with Fantastic Four as Reed Richards and
Sue Storm issues an added bonus
coincidence that they're married in real
life too they have that chemistry that's
so critical for those two characters and
because it's a reboot obviously the
story is going to have to be an origin
story but they're not going to completely
recycle the same stuff over and over
just the same way that they didn't
recycle Uncle Ben
during Captain America Civil War but
they told that story in a way that you
had not seen a billion other times in
other spider-man movies so it'll be the
same thing with Fantastic Four but
number one the real reason why they're
not doing new Wolverine or a new x-men
before new Fantastic Four even though
they're way more popular characters is
because they have almost like 90% of the
Fantastic Four stuff ready to go the
timing is way better the Logan movie was
way too good of an ending for the Hugh
Jackman Wolverine and too recent as well
as x-men Dark Phoenix scorching the
earth of the fandom for the x-men
characters if you haven't heard the
stories Disney had to take a huge loss
on that movie right after they bought
Fox they took a big enough loss that had
actually hurt their stock price when
they made the announcement
so Disney's going to let the dust settle on
those x-men characters for a good long
while before you see any of them pop
back up again and talk about honoring
Stanley's legacy Marvel's first family
they came before the x-men in the comics
we all talked about doing these
characters right now that Stanley isn't
with us anymore we're not going to see any
more Stanley cameos Kevin Feige is a big
believer in that so that just makes them
a much bigger priority on the docket
than the x-men characters right now the
earliest we could see that Fantastic
Four movie is 2023 2023 is a little bit
better because that's around the time
that Avengers 5 is going to get started
Philip had enough time during Marvel
phase 4 movies like Doctor Strange in
the multiverse of madness to explain
weirder stuff as well as the Eternals
movie to explain the basis for mutants
in the MCU and think about it this way
too you bring in the Fantastic Four you
bring in Silver Surfer Galactus and
Doctor Doom because now that Marvel kind
of lost the spider-man characters they
can't really use Norman Osborn as a mega
Avengers level villain dr. doom just
slid up the bench as the new top pick as
huge earth-based Marvel villain in The
Avengers movies they just re-released
spider-man far from home in theaters
there's an extended cut with a whole
bunch of new scenes if you don't want to
go see it don't worry I will post a
breakdown of all the scenes while you
wait for everything click here for my
brand new spider-man Sony Marvel update
and click here for my breakdown of the
footage from the brand new Avatar The
Last Airbender Netflix series thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!